se confirma que el antonov desaparecido
hoy en la península de kamchatka en el
extremo oriental de rusia ha caído al
mar y van 28 personas a bordo esta
mañana se ha identificado ya el lugar
donde ha caído el aparato según las
agencias rusas se enviaron de inmediato
buques al lugar y según las últimas
informaciones ya se han encontrado
restos del fuselaje la comunicación con
el aparato se perdió cuando iba a
aterrizar en paraná que es un poblado de
unos 3.000 habitantes situado en el
noroeste de la península de kamchatka
según la agencia de transporte aéreo
rosaviatsia las condiciones
meteorológicas en el momento del
aterrizaje eran complicadas y las nubes
tapan las montañas cerca del aeródromo
el antonov 26 había salido de la ciudad
de petropávlovsk kamchatski con seis
miembros de la tripulación y 22
pasajeros a bordo en la operación de
búsqueda y rescate participan dos
helicópteros un avión del ministerio de
emergencias y grupos de rescatistas a
estas horas parece claro que no hay
supervivientes